When Sicily's Mount Etna erupts, it really is a beautiful sight.
It looks like an amazing, powerful fireworks show.
But there's one audience that's watching for a different reason.
A group of scientists have made watching Mount Etna their life's work.
They're volcanologists.
Salvatore Caffo is the main volcanologist on Mount Etna.
From his office at Mount Etna National Park, Caffo has a good view of the power of the volcano.
Caffo's responsibility is to watch the unpredictable mountain and keep records of its activity.
Mount Etna, or simply Etna, is more than 10,000 feet high, which makes it Europe's highest active volcano.
Caffo grew up in the city of Catania, less than 30 miles from Etna's craters.
He was always extremely interested in the mountain.
When he was just 11 years old, he knew that he wanted to make volcanoes an important part of his life.
At the park, Caffo's task is important.
He must work towards understanding the volcano's role on Earth.
He must also help others to understand it.
Mount Etna is a mountain where there's a very strong interaction between man and nature.
And you can't leave that out of the equation.
Mount Etna began to form 600,000 years ago.
It started at the place where the African and Eurasian tectonic plates come together...
...deep under the surface of the Earth.
On Etna, there are more than 100 craters and cones in a huge volcanic area.
These craters and cones indicate the places where gases and magma escape from under the Earth's crust.
Today, thousands of people live on and around the volcano.
For centuries, people have been farming the rich volcanic earth and growing their food there.
Now, people also make money from tourists who come to see the eruptions.
The town of Nicolosi is just 12 miles from the crater.
The village was first built more than 800 years ago,...
...but eruptions from Etna have destroyed it twice.
The people who live there know that Nicolosi could be destroyed by Etna again.
Yet, the town also benefits from being so close to the volcano.
It's an interesting relationship between man and land.
There is the risk, we know that.
We are conscious of this risk.
If it's destroyed, well, we rebuild.